hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring in this video we're going to be
quickly going through seven important
formulas you want to know for the ECT
math section so let's get right into
this video I do want to mention that if
you find this video helpful and you want
to dig in deeper I've got an a CT math
video course available it's um it's
called a huge a CT math review it's goes
through 65 concepts that are important
and helpful to know to master the a CT
math section and I'll have a link for
that but let's get into this video
talking about the first formula which is
expected value and essentially what
expected value is is what you would
expect to get on average if you were to
run a number of trials you know a number
of trials over and over again given the
outcomes which are the x values here and
then the probability of those outcomes
occurring and you can see from this
formula looks a little complicated but
it's not as difficult as it looks
basically what you're doing is you're
taking you know the outcome which in
this case would be eight like say for
example you know you were doing some
kind of experiment eight was the outcome
and you say well what's the probability
of that outcome 20 percent you would
multiply these together eight times
point two zero you would multiply this
outcome nine times the probability that
it happens okay and then ten times the
probability that it occurs and then you
would add those together and that would
be what you expect to get on average
over a long number of trials so this is
an important formula to note for the
acct expected value the second formula
that we're looking at here is slope and
that's another important formula to know
for the acct math section and you can
see the formulas right here you learn
this before in your math class but
basically you're taking the difference
in the y-values divided by the
difference in the x-values
and one thing you want to pay attention
to is that the order is important so you
can do y2 minus y1 over x2 minus x1 and
that will give you the slope or the
angle of the line okay or you can
reverse it you could say y1 minus y2
over X 1 minus X 2 again it'll also give
you an idea of the angle of the line
okay but what you don't want to do is do
y2 minus y1 over X 1 minus X 2 see how I
switched up the order you don't want to
do that because you'll get a different
result
so knowing slope is important for the
acct things like whether lines are
parallel they have the same
slope or perpendicular they have the
opposite reciprocal slopes but knowing
this formula is definitely a good one
for the AC T the third formula we're
looking at is the distance formula so
the distance formula is this right here
it's the difference between the two
x-coordinates of the points that you're
trying to find the distance between
squared plus the difference between the
two y-coordinates of the points that
you're looking at the distance between
squared you add those quantities
together and then you take the square
root and so that's how you would find
the distance between two points so
another good formula to know for the
math section of the acte the fourth
formula that we're looking at here for
the math section of AC T is the midpoint
formula and basically what the midpoint
formula does is it finds the point
that's halfway in between two end points
and what you do is you add the x
coordinates of the two points together
and divide by two and then you add the Y
coordinates of the two points together
and divide by two so it's like finding
an average but when you do that this is
going to be the coordinate of the
midpoint the point again halfway between
the two end points so again another
important formula Knoll midpoint v
formula that we're looking at here for
the math section of ACG is the
Pythagorean theorem and the Pythagorean
theorem just helps us to find the
missing side in a right triangle so if
you have a right triangle like this and
the two legs are the a and the B sides
the one that's across from the right
angle that's the hypotenuse that's
called the C side and as long as you
know a squared plus B squared equals C
squared you can solve for any one of the
missing sides in a right triangle so
Pythagorean theorem another good one to
know for the math section of the AC T
okay the sixth formula that we're
looking at here in this video is
probability and what probability is it's
the chance that something can happen but
as far as a formula goal is you take the
number of successes basically what you
want divided by the total possible
outcomes the total number of things that
could happen so for example if you just
a very basic example if you had a hat
and in the Hat there was one red marble
and let's say there was two blue marbles
right and you say what's the probability
I pick a red marble well it's one chance
right one success out of three possible
that probability would be one-third so
this is just a very basic example but
this is a good formula you want to know
for the math section of a CT okay last
but not least the average formula is an
important one for the math section of a
CT
so what an average is is you take up the
total divided by how many that you're
averaging and that gives you the average
so for example if you're trying to
figure out what your average test score
is you would add up all the points from
your your tests and you would divide by
the number of tests that you took and
that would be your average but on a CT
sometimes I'll you know give you the
average and you might have to find out
how many tests or what the total is or
what one of the missing test scores are
like that but if you know this formula
you can substitute in what you know
solve for what you don't know so this
has just been a real quick video about
the key formulas that you want to know
for the math section of the AC T but
like I said at the beginning if you want
to go deeper I recommend the huge a CT
math review video course that I have
available on my mario's math tutoring
youtube channel about page I've got a
link there and I'll put a link in this
video so definitely check that out and
good luck on the math section of a CT